c'est quoi le plus difficile à gérer
dans votre couple la différence de
taille ou la différence d'âge
la dernière rebonsoir bonsoir Je vous
regardez l'arrivée pendant la pub à 1 m
82 même un 6 vous avez une vue à couper
le souffle sur la calvitie de Laurent
Baffie quelle calvitie vous avez des
jambes immenses
ça doit prendre du temps pour vous
épiler non
je préfère que on en parle tout de suite
quand Laurent Baffie travaillait pour
votre mari Arnaud Lagardère sur Europe 1
il a tagué fuck Lagardère sur les je
sais sur les mecs
parce que j'encule les patrons quoi
non mais
sur les murs du studio alors si ça avait
été vous effectivement ça aurait été une
info mais de la part de ma fille c'est
vraiment grave il s'excuse d'ailleurs
pas du tout
en aucun cas c'est mon boulot on paye
pour ça pour faire le bouffon c'est mon
métier voilà tu as été viré quand même
oui sur ma demande parce que je
demandais que les gens écrivent à la
commande en dur pour me faire virer et
je lui ai dit qu'on prenait pas et au
bout de 4 ans ils m'ont ils m'ont viré
quoi alors en préparant cette interview
j'ai trouvé une phrase qui vous raconte
parfaitement vous avez été emmerdé toute
votre enfance parce que vous étiez plus
belle que les autres et vous allez être
emmerdé toute votre vie parce que vous
êtes plus riche que les autres
alors vous êtes donc l'épouse d'Arnaud
Lagardère on a beaucoup jasé sur votre
histoire à ses débuts cette liaison
entre un mannequin de 20 ans et un
milliardaire plus vieux de 30 ans et
force est de constater
que 7 ans plus tard vous êtes toujours
aussi fusionnelle avec Arnaud et vous
avez trois beaux enfants et Arnaud a
l'air heureux il est heureux et je suis
heureuse
alors
56 ans vous 26 il mesure 1m65 vous
mesurez en mètre 82
c'est quoi le plus difficile à gérer
dans votre couple la différence de
taille ou la différence d'âge
un moment ça m'avait blessé évidemment
toutes ces remarques au tout début de
notre relation mais aujourd'hui on en
rigole parce qu'effectivement les
préjugés on aura toujours des critiques
on aura toujours on peut pas plaire à
tout le monde et voilà moi je suis une
femme très heureuse une maman épanouie
on a trois magnifiques enfants et voilà
ça plaît ça plaît pas
[Applaudissements]
en tous les cas il y a pas de différence
dans le look parce que vous êtes
toujours habillé à peu près dans les
mêmes couleurs tous les deux voilà donc
quand il est en noir vous êtes confonds
[Applaudissements]
je suppose que c'est pas on n'est pas
l'unique couple à sa sortie non alors
jade vous êtes né le 26 septembre
1990 là je me lance à houlou
et j'ai bien fait Saint-Lambert c'est
facile en Belgique votre père était
gérant de supermarché votre mère
s'occupait de ses cinq enfants il
divorce quand vous avez 15 ans et vous
vivez très mal la souffrance de votre
mère à ce moment-là exactement oui je
pense que comme beaucoup d'enfants j'ai
énormément souffert de de cette
séparation parce que mon papa par terre
venait par terre et ça a été ça a été
très difficile pour mais bon
on s'en sort et c'est ce qui nous forge
le caractère et c'est ce qui nous rend
plus fort en général alors à l'école on
se moque de vous que vous êtes trop
grande on vous appelle la girafe on vous
appelle l'asperge moi je suis pas je
suis pas à plaindre je suis pas je suis
pas non plus faire mon petit Calimero
mais c'est vrai que quand on est enfant
on a nos états d'âme et il y a des
choses qui nous blessent et on a un
dosage un peu différent de souffrance et
c'est vrai que moi j'en souffrais
beaucoup et quand je revenais à la
maison ce qui me faisait du bien c'était
écrire j'étais dans ma chambre et
j'écris jeunes
et le seul moment où vous oubliez ce
complexe ce qu'on fait vos premières
photos pour Carrefour ils avaient besoin
d'une fille qui puisse porter une
culotte 10 ans mais avec un 85A il y en
avait pas 50000 et vous vous dites là
c'est le moment d'y aller vous y allez
et vous le faites et c'est le début
d'une très belle carrière de mannequin
surtout en Italie au départ au défilé
quand même beau Armani vous faites le
début du défilé la fin du défilé enfin
vous êtes vraiment reconnu à ce moment
la plus jeune mannequin à 13 ans haute
couture est prête à porter oui les
Italiens vous appellent la bambine la
Piccola
un jour quand même vous avez une robe
échancrée qui s'ouvre pendant le défilé
vous avez 14 ans on voit votre poitrine
mais ça fait un scandale quand même et
pourtant du stylisme m'avait mis
vraiment du scotch juste avant de passer
mais il s'avère que en défilant juste à
la fin du podium la robe s'est ouverte
malgré les scotch n'avait pas tout vu et
ça évidemment faire un choc je les
comprends et sur le moment
j'ai compris tout de suite la police
mais c'est vrai que quand on est enfant
on se rend pas compte on voit on voit
pas le mal on a cette naïveté quand on
est enfant la jalousie devient ce
moment-là insupportable il y a même un
jour une fille qui vous fait tomber qui
vous crache dessus et ça se termine à
l'hôpital
mais je vais pardonner je vais pardonner
oui parce qu'elle s'est excusée quelques
années après alors j'ai pardonné mais je
l'oublie pas alors c'est là que vous
rencontrez sur les réseaux sociaux
Richard Gasquet et c'est en 2010 alors
que vous êtes réfugiés à New York après
une histoire d'amour malheureuse avec le
footballeur Émile npanza que Richard
Gasquet vous présente à Arnaud Lagardère
et très rapidement
ça devient du sérieux 20 minutes
vous l'avez fait beaucoup attendre quand
même c'est pas vu pendant au début
on regarde
très aux gens qui sont intéressés à le
voir que c'est du sérieux c'est ça
combien et puis bientôt 6 le 14 juillet
fête nationale française bientôt Simon
vous êtes rencontrés dans quel cadre
dans un cadre parisien c'était dans mon
bureau j'habitais venu me voir parce
qu'elle avait un travail à faire et
après on s'est revu à Londres mais en
réalité ça a commencé à Londres
alors ce que les gens pensent beaucoup
c'est que un amour comme ça pourrait ne
pas tenir alors qu'en fait c'est pas du
tout vrai parce que vous étiez ici pour
aujourd'hui pour pour le prouver alors
c'est un amour qui peut tenir plusieurs
années plusieurs années pourquoi
toujours trouver
les gens pensent beaucoup parfois
beaucoup trop pas toujours mal mais
parfois un peu mal c'est pas de manière
intentionnée c'est c'est juste parce que
les gens aiment parler aiment penser à
la place des autres en tout cas nous
quand on pense à nous on se on se donne
pas de limite par définition
alors votre maman
est très complice avec Arnaud elle
n'hésite pas à levaner
des images elle l'appelle petit Nono
elle est très familière avec lui ils ont
une très
il y a une vidéo que je ne passerai pas
parce que ici c'est la discrétion
c'est celle où elle lui dit que son
pantalon est trop moulant et il dit je
vais quand même pas me la couper
Cassandre est-ce que Cassandra qui est
sorti avec le fils d'Arnaud Lagardère
Alexandre et ce qu'ils sont toujours
ensemble
petite fille dans mon que mixte viens
faire le début vient fermer
[Applaudissements]
et maintenant on passe à la bande
dessinée alors ça s'appelle amberblay
tome 1 la fille de Merton Castle le
scénario est de vous les dessins sont de
budget et c'est publié aux éditions
Glénat voilà alors le pire c'est
l'histoire d'Amber Blake abandonnée à
l'âge de 5 ans qui grandit au sein d'un
réseau d'école pour enfants
issus de milieu défavorisés qui
s'appelle Cleveland c'est des enfants
dont le potentiel
intellectuel est très important et au
Cleverland de Londres donc elle réalise
que le directeur est un pervers assez
diabolique qui abuse des jeunes élèves
voilà elle s'échappe elle est recueillie
par une organisation secrète qui combat
les trafics d'organes institution la
pédophilie et avec le beau matmolan
elle se transforme en justicière j'en
dirai pas plus parce que il y a plein de
twist il y a plein de rebondissements
c'est bien fait super dessin en plus
alors voilà c'est bon vous avez créé une
héroïne qui est vous en mieux quoi avec
complètement 100 fois mieux complètement
tout le monde vous demande si vous
voulez faire un film avec ça j'imagine
non beaucoup de beaucoup de personnes me
le demandent et je vous répondrai que ce
serait un rêve évidemment de pouvoir
mais surtout j'aimerais faire une série
télé j'ai tellement de choses à vous
raconter sur un bordelke
est déjà écrit et sort en janvier 2018
qui a souffert énormément parce qu'elle
a été violée torturée je parle de sujets
qui me révoltent depuis toujours et
c'est vraiment
un message d'espoir parce que c'est pour
prouver que même on est en souffert
énormément on peut s'en sortir mais
surtout il faut s'en sortir
est-ce que vous dans le milieu vous avez
fréquenté quand vous étiez mannequin
est-ce que vous avez été victime de
prédateurs
contre les gens non c'est important de
le dire
c'est pour tout toutes les personnes qui
ont vécu ces horreurs moi j'ai pas été
victime de ça mais j'ai été élevé en
Belgique à l'époque de Marc Dutroux ça
doit jouer non
ça vous traumatise quand vous êtes
enfant oui alors évidemment dans mon
pays ça a été beaucoup plus médiatisé
que dans les autres pays mais
malheureusement la pédophilie et tout et
tous ces crimes se passent tous les
jours c'est horrible
Jade
il serait pas étonné qu'on fasse une
interview par amour
[Musique]
jade est-ce que par amour vous pourriez
vous convertir à une autre religion le
musulmanisme est-ce que vous seriez
prête à vous convertir aux musulmanisme
Arnaud me le demanderait pas parce que
il est chrétiens mais mais oui est-ce
que par amour pour y vivre à Limoges par
amour je le suivrai n'importe où
[Applaudissements]
vous seriez prête à prendre 20 kilos
j'ai déjà pris beaucoup de kilos c'était
j'ai pris 26 pour ma première grossesse
28 pour la deuxième et 30 pour la
dernière est-ce que par amour si Arnaud
la Gardère vous le demandez vous
pourriez vous mettre à l'héroïne
à la bibine ou au régime
c'est super prends-en
non mais par amour elle l'empêcherait de
faire ça déjà il aurait jamais
[Applaudissements]
commencé
est-ce que vous seriez prêt à lui
fournir un alibi à vous dénoncer à sa
place ou à attendre 20 ans à sa sortie
de prison
est-ce que par amour il est prête à
accepter qu'il maîtresse
mais si vous l'aimez vous avez envie
qu'il soit heureuse si heureux avec la
maîtresse
à aller dans des clubs échangistes par
amour par amour par amour un jour
vous seriez prête à devenir son esclave
sexuel
vous en avez des questions
mais je suis déjà en vous l'a pas dit
quelle est la question Clotilde de
courant
donc Clotilde Courau elle avait répondu
oui donc on va voir est-ce que par amour
vous seriez prête à embrasser 100 fois
ces chaussettes sales
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditube abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu